we all know that it doesn't pay to
gamble but a week ago I heard a paradox
that seems to show the opposite that you
can earn money whenever you gamble let
me show you how it works for a
particular game but afterwards I'll show
you how it generalizes to any the game I
heard it in the context of was roulette
apparently there's this way to play the
game where you just need to guess
whether something is either black or red
and both have equal probability you
better set an amount of money and if
you're right they give you the amount
you bettered but if you lose you pay
them this is a game of pure chance if
you play this game a lot you wouldn't
expect to win or lose anything by the
way if you played this in a real casino
the odds are slightly stacked against
you so that they do make money but that
doesn't make a big difference to this
paradox so let's look at the fair game
for now it seems like there's nothing
you can do to improve your chance of
making money but let's think about this
strategy what if you said I'll always
bet red first time I'll bet - if I win
I'll stop otherwise I'll play this game
again but this time I'll bet 4 and if I
lose I'll bet 8 etc etc then say you won
on round 3 you win 8 which covers all of
your previous losses the beauty of this
is you will win eventually and whenever
that is you win back everything you lost
and then some you might say yeah but the
amounts of money you're betting every
time get huge quickly and that's true
but it's pretty unlikely that you'll
even lose that many times in a row I
mean the probability that you'll lose
just three rounds is only one in eight
the idea behind this strategy is to
chase your losses you know that thing
that people tell you you should never do
if you've lost three rounds then so far
you've lost 2 plus 4 plus 8 which equals
14 so you bet 2 higher than your total
loss that means that if you win this
round you get back everything you've
lost plus 2 more you can check this for
yourself but this works for whatever
round you finish up on you bet your
total losses so far plus 2 so whenever
you play this game as long as you go
through until you eventually
when around you always make two but this
seems like a contradiction you're not
supposed to consistently make money
playing this game you're supposed to
break even
it gets worse than that because you can
apply this strategy to any betting
situation no matter the odds you just
bet a little bit more than your total
losses so far but wait before you go and
bet on your house you can see that this
is clearly stupid for most betting
situations most of the time bets are
sacked well against you let's say you're
playing a game where you have a one in
ten chance of winning each bet which is
not at all unrealistic then the chance
that you'll even lose twelve games in a
row is still stupidly high at about
thirty percent but at that point you'll
have spent about eight thousand and
you're still likely to lose more so ya
don't actually go and do this in real
life please the strategy doesn't
actually work it's obvious why not when
the odds are like this but when the odds
are at fifty fifty like in the roulette
game it's hard to see what the problem
is and that's where the paradox is I'm
going to give you a week to see if you
can figure it out it took me a lot of
frustrated hours with a friend until we
cracked it but it was good fun to think
about which is why I wanted to tell you
guys it's a really interesting paradox
and if you do figure it out here are
some other variations that you might
want to try what if you decide not to be
too greedy and you only bet your total
losses plus one each time instead of two
or what if you get super greedy and you
bet your losses plus some growing amount
in these two scenarios see how quickly
the amount of money you bet grows and
what you expect your winnings to be if
you need some hints I have some small
ones in the description now good luck
try it with a friend so you can discuss
it I highly recommend that Oh but
promise me one thing that you won't go
and gamble this week